[Music]  should i neutralize them they'll do  anything come on  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  under control general I'll let you know  if we need you  unacceptable unseat your asses down  there immediately I want a full court  evacuation now I'm shutting you down god  damn it  did you hear with the general sent I  said down  [Music]  [Music]  locked down the entire facility  immediately target still moving towards  below evacuate the main hall  sending backup heavy weapons issue  General Quarters  [Music]  [Music]  gemination sir system readings a red  line  [Music]  shut down all power to the main hall  show them the way out would fight him  outside  [Music]  [Music]  you